>>All: Nobody likes me, everybody
hates me, guess I'll go eat worms.
Long thin slimy ones, short fat juicy
ones, itsy bitsy fuzzy wuzzy worms.
>>Narrator: These first graders at
Newsome Park Elementary dig worms,
and they've designed an entire
project around them with the help
of their teacher, Cathy Huemer.
>>Oh, there's one.
>>Cathy: You wanna
pick it up, Cameron?
>>When they wanted to do
animals, they had idea.
"Let's do snakes, let's do you know,
horses, let's do dogs, you know."
And so I keep raising
question to them, "Well, why?
What is it that you wanna know?"
Well, they wanna know about, "Well,
where do these animals live?"
So I said to them, "Are
we really gonna be able
to go look for snakes, you know?
That might not be possible.
Can you think of something
else that might be similar?"
And someone just said,
"Let's do worms."
Said, "Okay, we what
do we know about worms?
What do we need to
find out about worms?"
Phase one, which leads us into
phase two, which is the field work,
the actual work that they're doing,
whether it's field trips,
lab work, experiments.
>>Student: We did a
experiment on dead worms.
We smelled 'em and
they didn't smell good.
And we had to pick 'em
up and feel the vein.
>>Narrator: Worms are just one of the
subjects students explore in depth
at Newsome Park, a K through
five science magnet school
in Newport News, Virginia,
that has embraced the concept
of project based learning.
>>See the different types
of fish that're here?
>> Narrator: Each class picks a
topic to study for the semester.
They then plan a research phase
which includes field trips
to gather information.
>>Student: Transportation,
four facts.
>>Narrator: At the conclusion of the
project, they share their findings
in oral presentations, digital
slideshows, and display boards
which are viewed and critiqued
by their parents and their peers.
>>Peter: Project based learning
was really the delivery model
that we felt would allow kids
to learn, and really learn
about what they wanna learn about.
I mean, so many years, we've
been pumping kids full of stuff
that we think is appropriate,
and really, in many instances,
maybe that was successful, but it's
much more successful and exhilarating
when kids have the
input that we allow them
to have here at Newsome Park.
>>How do you spell "minerals?"
>>Narrator: Students here have
chosen to study everything
from space flight to homelessness.
This first grade class decided
to explore cystic fibrosis,
a disease affecting one
of their classmates.
>>One of our students has CF and
we're trying to learn about CF
to see what it is, how it works.
Mucus starts getting into the
person's lungs and pancreas.
And we hope to find out
that there's a cure for CF.
>>Narrator: Students use programs
like PowerPoint and a series
of thinking maps to turn
good project concepts
into exemplary work products.
>>Peter: The students of today are
really more in tune with everything
that they have coming in at them
visually, so using the technology
to represent their learning has
actually increased the quality
of their work.
>>Narrator: Even with the
latest technology tools,
project based learning can
be challenging for teachers.
>>Patty: -- for us, and so we came up
with some questions for Miss Harbuck
and she's coming in today
to tell us more, isn't she?
>>Yep.
>>Oh good, okay.
>>Patty: It's easier to
teach out of a textbook,
where this day it tells
me to do this,
and this day it tells me to do that.
So in a way, you've gotta be willing
to work a little harder
too to do it this way.
Even though it looks like the
kids are doing all the hard work,
there's a lotta planning that
goes on behind it to make sure
that the work is there for them.
>>Do we have anybody in
this classroom with asthma?
>>All: Yes.
>>Patty: Yes, we do.
And--
>>Narrator: Since several of Miss
Vreeland's students have asthma,
they're studying pets, focusing on
pets that don't make asthma worse.
As part of every research
project, students seek out experts,
like a guest speaker
from the local hospital..
>>Teacher: Your lungs are made
up of different kinds of tissue.
>>Patty: They know that they don't
have all the answers, and it's okay.
They also know that Miss V
doesn't have all the answers,
and it doesn't bother her a bit.
And so we sit back and we go, "Okay,
well who can we call,
who can we ask?"
>>Thank you, thank you.
>>Narrator: At lunchtime, students
get to test their social skills
and basic math, selling everything
from Walkathon pledges to marigolds.
>>Student: We have marigolds, we have
two of these left, and mixed flowers.
Those just all type of flowers,
like this flower, this whole patch,
it'll probably be like
that when they grow.
>>Narrator: The plant business grew
out of a class investigation
into the stock market.
>>Robert: We talked about
what the stock market was.
We actually invested in fancy stocks.
We were thinking about
investing in some penny stocks
and seeing how much money we
could make on the stock exchange.
However, that became repetitive
and truthfully, somewhat boring.
>>What you wanna buy?
>>Narrator: Instead, the class
decided to create their own business.
They bought seeds, grew the
plants and made sales brochures,
funding the entire operation through
the sale of flower power stock.
>>Robert: We ended up going around,
we sold ten cent shares of our stock
in our company and we actually
raised over seventy-five dollars.
>>Narrator: But the success
of the fourth grade plant
projects sowed the seeds
of another lesson in
real life learning.
It led to the mounting of
a hostile takeover attempt
by Miss Shields' fifth graders.
>>Student: Miss Shields' classes,
the fifth grade, is planning to take
and buy all the stock and leave them
for like five percent of their stock
and take over their business.
So we'll be in total
control of their business.
>>Narrator: The process of learning
project based lessons has had a
positive impact on everything from
test scores to classroom behavior.
>>Peter: Our test scores
have improved, mainly I think
because of the fact that
we've connected the learning
to real world problems,
and the integration
of technology has helped the students
to actually product quality products.
So that's the reward, and to me, it's
been probably the most rewarding way
of teaching and learning that I've
experienced in my thirty years.
>>It's a red wiggler.
>>Narrator: For more
information on what works
in public education,
go to Edutopia.org